après la première étape contre la montre
les spécialistes de la route s'aventurer
dans le bassin de la Boissière sur un
circuit de 3 km très glissant il fallait
donc limiter la casse pour ne pas
dégringoler au classement c'est vraiment
technique et surtout être prudent de
manière à faire la chute
ça c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le
piège quoi si on arrive un peu trop vite
tout de suite on tombe pour ce premier
trophée West Yvelines ils étaient 180
par temps issus de toutes les
fédérations de vélo cyclotourisme VTT ou
root et au milieu du peloton le 56 mois
de 16 ans quand un Fabre a remporté la
première étape de Bois-d'Arcy dans sa
catégorie dans la Boissière il arrive
sur son terrain de prédilection une
stratégie particulière je sais pas mais
peut-être dans les parties techniques
savoir bien relancer avec mettre de la
force certaines parties après dans le
dans les parties sous bois savoir gérer
son effort pour mettre tout ce qu'on a
pour la fin après le dernier contre la
montre de dimanche après-midi quand un
Fabre devra finalement laisser son
maillot de leader aller son Ia David
France qui remporte ce premier trophée
West Yvelines